the massive scope of the mcu has allowed
marvel studios to create a sprawling
interconnected universe built on a
shared continuity and much like the
comics the movies are based on that
means things can get pretty complicated
the marvel cinematic universe doesn't
start with tony stark getting kidnapped
in 2008 carol danvers being taken to
holla in the 90s or even with steve
rogers volunteering for the super
soldier program in the 40s instead like
most universes this one starts at the
big bang going chronologically the first
event we see in the mcu is the creation
of the infinity stones as the collector
explains in guardians of the galaxy they
were formed from the six singularities
that caused the universe to explode into
existence before being scattered across
the universe
that of course was billions of years ago
but millions of years before we get to
the present day mcu ego the living
planet comes into existence and starts
seeding worlds with his essence in an
attempt to create another celestial
being like himself
thousands of years ago as we find out in
thor the dark world malakith the
accursed laid siege to asgard and was
fought off by bore the father of odin
four vanquished malekith which turns out
to be a temporary solution while we
don't know exactly when it happens the
next chronological event we see from our
characters is odin's conquest of the
nine realms alongside his first child
hella goddess of death during this era
the magic warhammer mjolnir is forged in
the heart of a dying star and long
before thor hella carries it into battle
once the realms have been conquered
hella's bloodthirsty nature causes odin
to turn against her and in the battle
that follows hella destroys the
valkyries the sole surviving valkyrie
flees from asgard and eventually winds
up drunk and depressed on sakar hella is
then imprisoned in another dimension by
odin who literally covers up all traces
of her existence sometime after that but
still pretty far back odin and friega
have a son thorpe shortly thereafter
odin slays the frost giant lofty and
adopts his son loki as his own as
children they did not exactly get along
he transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that i love snakes so i went to
pick up the snake to admire it and he
transformed back into himself and he was
like yeah it's me and he stabbed me
also millions of years before the
present day a meteorite made of the
super metal vibranium strikes earth and
africa drastically affecting the
surrounding area much much later this
area becomes the country of wakanda when
a warrior shaman receives a vision from
the goddess bast and founds a dynasty of
kings known as the black panthers
believe it or not there is not a whole
lot that happens between the unification
of wakanda and the 20th century the
first big event that we see in the
movies is the arrival of well the first
avenger in 1942 a nazi officer known as
the red skull creates a splinter group
called hydra with the discovery of one
of the infinity stones he creates a
technologically advanced army of his own
that same year steve rogers volunteers
for an experimental attempt at creating
a super soldier using a technique
created by dr abraham erskine the
project works giving steve the body of
marvel's hunkiest chris
when erskine is assassinated the
research is lost rather than risking
their only super soldier by sending him
to fight in the war the army gives steve
the code name captain america and uses
him primarily as a spokesman to sell war
bonds eventually steve becomes an active
soldier in the war leading a strike team
called the howling commandos on one of
their missions his best friend bucky
falls from a train in the mountains
steve believes him to be dead but he's
actually taken into custody by the
soviet army and brainwashed into
becoming a super assassin codenamed
winter soldier
after attempting to use the tesseract
the red skull is sucked into a wormhole
and somehow winds up on the distant
planet vormir serving as a sort of
spectral guardian for the soul stone
as for steve he crashes a bomber jet
into the arctic to keep hydra from
destroying new york he is also presumed
dead but survives frozen in suspended
animation for the next 66 years while
things are pretty quiet for the mcu
between 1945 and 1995 there are a few
notable exceptions peggy carter
continues to work for the strategic
science reserve first in new york in
1946 and then in los angeles alongside
howard stark in 1947
around this time the soviet union
produces the first graduates of its
brutal red room facility where orphaned
girls are trained as spies and assassins
sometimes shortly after this steve
rogers travels back in time from 2023 to
reunite with peggy she continues to work
in military intelligence for the next
few decades with stark whose defense
contracts turned stark industries into
the world's leading arms manufacturer by
1970 both of them are working out of ssr
headquarters at camp lehigh along with a
few other notable figures including
arnhem zola his body dies in 1972 and
his brain is transferred into a computer
data bank that continues hydra's
infiltration of the government also hank
pym is working here assisted by bill
foster in his experiments with the
size-changing pym particles that will
allow him and his wife janet van dyne to
become the original ant-man and wasp
in 1974 howard stark launches the stark
expo displaying the city of the future
powered by a clean energy arc reactor
that's about the size of a house for
some reason he also hides the structure
of a new element in the arrangement of
the buildings which is the kind of
science it pays to not think too hard
about in 1980 ego comes to earth winning
the heart of meredith quill and nine
months later her son peter is born in
1987 janet van dyne is lost in the
quantum realm after she and hank pym
attempt to stop a rogue soviet missile
targeting the united states in 1988
meredith quill dies from brain cancer
intentionally caused by ego leaving her
son a mixtape of classic rock favorites
before she dies peter is then abducted
by a band of outer space outlaws called
the ravagers who give him a pretty
terrible childhood yondu is the guy who
abducted me kicked the crap out of me so
i could learn to fight and kept me in
terror by threatening to eat me eat you
yeah in 1989 pym resigns from the ssr
after finding out that they intended to
use his pym particles to create weapons
the organization has also now been
renamed the strategic homeland
intervention enforcement and logistics
division
that's quite a mouthful i know we're
working on it also that year air force
captain carol danvers who uses the
callsign avenger volunteers for a test
flight of a light speed engine powered
by the tesseract when they're shot down
by the cree a militaristic alien race
constantly at war with the
shape-shifting scrolls carol's body is
overloaded with the tesseract's energy
giving her incredible powers and also
wiping her memory a cree soldier named
yong rog abducts her and takes her back
to his homeland hala here she's made to
believe that she's actually a cree named
viers
meanwhile while all of this is happening
on earth things continue to develop in
space thanos an incredibly powerful
alien from the planet titan who's
obsessed with balance begins to seek out
the infinity stones lane waste to half
of the population of entire planets he
also occasionally abducts young
survivors training them as soldiers
assuming that most of the more humanoid
characters are around the same age as
the people portraying them than his two
most notable adoptions happen in the
late 80s or early 90s gamora and nebula
every time the two sisters sparred
gamora wins and thanos systematically
replaces pieces of nebula's body with
cybernetic parts
in 1991 the soviet government sends the
winter soldier to assassinate howard and
maria stark making it look like a car
accident their brilliant slacker son
tony is left in charge of stark
industries along with obadiah staying as
ceo unbeknownst to tony stain makes a
tidy profit from secret arms deals with
terrorist groups in 1992 king t'chaka of
wakanda goes to oakland california to
investigate arms deals involving stolen
vibranium the culprit is his brother
njobu who is killed in the altercation
njobu's son eric is a witness to the
whole thing and grows up craving revenge
in 1995 carol danvers still without her
memories of earth returns to her home
planet after escaping from the scrolls
she teams up with shield agents nick
fury and phil coulson to stop the
scrolls from invading earth it turns out
that the cree are the bad guys with yong
rog and ronin the accuser on route in
search of the infinity stones that will
end their war of conquest once and for
all
finally at full power carol fights them
off and in the process an alien cat
scratches nick fury's left eye blinding
it and causing him to sport a
fashionable eye patch for the rest of
the franchise before she journeys back
into space carol gives fury a pager that
can summon her in case of a dire
emergency inspired by carol and her
original call sign fury lays the
groundwork for the avengers initiative a
program designed to create a team of
super powered heroes to deal with
large-scale threats like alien invasions
in 1999 tony stark meets bioengineers
maya hansen and aldrich killian at a
conference in burns switzerland he's
very rude to aldrich who remembers that
as a sore point for about 14 years
throughout all of this hydra continues
its secret infiltration of shield and
all levels of the united states
government
in 2008 we finally catch up to the mcu
as it happens tony stark is
demonstrating his newest weapons in the
middle east when he's kidnapped by a
terrorist organization called the ten
rings in what will eventually be
revealed as a plot by staying to get
tony out of the pitcher while he's
imprisoned the terrorists forced him and
another captive dr ho yinsen who was
also at that fateful 1999 convention in
bern to make weapons for them instead
tony is able to recreate a miniaturized
arc reactor using it to stabilize a
piece of shrapnel that's lodged near his
heart it's impossible tony stark was
able to build this in a cave
with a box of scraps
the reactor also powers the iron man a
suit of weaponized armor built from
scrap which allows tony to escape after
jensen's death
he returns to america eats a
cheeseburger refines his design and
wipes out the ten rings in a brutally
effective display of the iron man's
weapons he also defeats stain who
attempts to kill tony and creates his
own massive suit of powered armor tony
then publicly reveals his identity
i am iron man
which causes nick fury to approach him
about the avengers initiative around the
same time as tony's capture dr bruce
banner is working on recreating the
super soldier program instead of
erskine's vita rays he uses gamma
radiation testing it on himself and
turning himself into a rampaging green
monstrous hulk whenever he gets angry
which is always after the hulk
inadvertently injures banner's
girlfriend betty ross he attempts to go
underground but returns to america in
search of a cure for his condition he
winds up dealing with a scientist named
samuel stearns whose attempt to recreate
the hulk turns special forces soldier
emile blonsky into the monstrous
abomination
six months after revealing his identity
publicly tony stark is called to testify
before congress because they are
justifiably concerned about a private
citizen building a suit of armor that
can vaporize a tank to create their own
version they turn to rival weapons
manufacturer justin hammer after tony's
friend colonel james rhodes delivers a
prototype iron man suit hammer and
russian scientist anton van koe reverse
engineer them into an army of
militarized drones stark also gets a new
personal assistant who is revealed to be
shield agent and red room defector
natasha romanov the black widow rhodes
gets his own suit of armor codenamed war
machine and he and tony team up to
defeat van koe and hammer speaking of
hammers while all this is happening on
earth there's other stuff going on in
the golden realm of asgard loki tricks
thor into antagonizing the frost giant
against odin's orders as a consequence
odin exiles thor to earth and enchances
hammer mjolnir whosoever holds of this
hammer
if he be worthy shall possess the power
it lands in new mexico where agent
coulson discovers it and a bunch of
locals try to yank it out of the ground
with pickup trucks thor eventually
proves himself worthy regains his hammer
and stops loki from staging a coup in
asgard in 2011 the crashed hydra plane
is discovered in the arctic shield thaws
out captain america and after realizing
that he's in the 21st century he teams
up with nick fury's avengers initiative
it turns out he was just in time in 2012
loki last seen a drift in space after
his failed coup in asgard is enlisted by
thanos to recover the tesseract from
earth in exchange thanos gives him
control of the chitauri a massive army
of high-minded destroyers loki agrees
because he's apparently in one of his
moods that day the result is the battle
of manhattan in which the avengers
captain america iron man thor black
widow hulk and hawkeye are gathered for
the first time as a team the good guys
win after loki is smashed against the
ground a lot but the battle is extremely
destructive the reconstruction is mostly
handled by the newly formed department
of damage control who take over the
lucrative contract and leave
construction foremen adrian tombs
embittered and in possession of advanced
technology in 2013 tony stark is left
with post-traumatic stress as a result
of the battle and his concept of the
universe suddenly expanding to include
gods aliens and other unknowable cosmic
forces
unfortunately this coincides with the
return of aldrich killian who's been
experimenting with maya hansen's
regenerative extremist treatment which
has a tendency to cause its subjects to
explode to cover his operations killian
creates a fictional terrace called the
mandarin hiring an actor named trevor
slattery to play him in threatening
videos needless to say tony and roadie
stop killian's plot after they uncover
the truth you want something take it
although the guns are all fake because
those wankers wouldn't trust me with the
real ones what hey do you fancy either
of the birds also malikith comes back
and thor fights him and loki becomes the
latest in a long line of presumed deaths
that actually aren't he stashes odin in
a retirement home in new york and then
takes his identity ruling over asgard
and putting on critically acclaimed
plays for the next two years
in 2014 hydra's decades-long plot to
infiltrate and take over america is
finally discovered by captain america
and black widow
before we get started
does anyone want to get out
they also learn that the winter soldier
is bucky barnes while cap fights to
restore his best friend's memories the
hydra plot is exposed and in the
aftermath shield collapses leaving the
avengers without the oversight and
support of the larger organization
tony stark and bruce banner then attempt
to recreate an artificial intelligence
that would help protect the world
unfortunately they goofed that plan up
big time instead creating a genocidal
robot named ultron who winds up
destroying an entire country sokovia
tony and banner decide that if at first
you don't succeed make another robot and
hope he's not genocidal they transform
tony's onboard ai jarvis into a much
more heroic ai called the vision
in the fight that follows the hulk
hijacks a quinjet and blasts off into
space landing on zakar also scarlet
witch and quicksilver two definitely not
mutants join the team quicksilver
immediately dies partly from bullets but
mostly because disney and fox were
having to fight over who had the
character's film rights the destruction
of sokovia also kills the family of
helmut zemo who then dedicates his life
to revenge while all that's going on
peter quill is out in space on a job to
steal a valuable orb which unbeknownst
to him contains an infinity stone that
puts him in the sights of both ronin the
accuser who's been looking for another
infinity stone since 1995 and thanos
ronan sends gamora after quill and winds
up running across drax a very literal
warrior whose family was killed by
thanos rocket a space raccoon who was
painfully experimented on and given
cybernetic enhancements and groot a
treat
after being imprisoned together the five
of them stage a jailbreak defeat ronin
in a dance-off recover the power stone
with the help of the power of friendship
and turn it over to the novacore a bunch
of space cops on the planet xandar
shortly thereafter thanos attacks xander
and recovers it for himself
in 2015 an electrical engineer named
scott lang gets out of prison and
stumbles onto hank pym's old size
changing equipment under the guidance of
him and his daughter hope lang becomes
the second ant-man and helps to keep the
pym particles from falling into the
hands of an evil arms dealer more
importantly it's likely somewhere around
this time that a kid named peter parker
is bitten by a radioactive spider and
tries to capitalize on his new
superpowers by becoming famous as
spider-man and fails to stop a robber
that later kills his uncle ben none of
this is covered in the mcu but you might
have seen five other movies about it the
following year seems helmet zemo's plan
to destroy the avengers reach its
fruition as the world responds to the
destruction of sokovia by trying to
install new governmental oversight over
the avengers zemo furthers the wedge
between captain america and iron man by
revealing that bucky was the one who
killed tony stark's parents
he also uses his control over bucky to
assassinate king t'chaka of wakanda
leading the king's son t'challa to take
over leadership of the country not to
mention the identity and powers of the
black panther the end result of all of
this is that the avengers break up the
ones loyal to cap go underground and
t'challa refuses to give zemo the death
he desires
while all this is going on dr steven
strange who lost the fine motor control
in his hands after a car accident seeks
out the ancient one and following her
death becomes a master of the mystic
arts he stops an invasion by dormammu a
demonic force from the dark dimension by
using the time stone to die over and
over again until the cosmic villain gets
annoyed enough to leave the earth alone
meanwhile the guardians of the galaxy
encounter and subsequently kill ego
before he can manipulate peter quill
into aiding his conquest of the entire
galaxy
in the absence of the avengers tony
stark begins to mentor peter parker as
spider-man peter tries to deal with the
wait for it evil arms dealer known as
the vulture who turns out to be none
other than adrian toombs his homecoming
date's dad the vulture is defeated
arrested and sent to prison but not
before he and several of peter's
classmates figure out spider-man's real
identity also tony stark finally
proposes to pepper potts in asgard thor
returns from two years of looking for
infinity stones in various realms to
discover loki's deception when they find
the real odin he's at the end of his
life and his death allows hella to
escape her millennia of imprisonment she
destroys mjolnir blasts the two brothers
into space and takes over asgard thor
winds up on zakar where he recruits hulk
and valkyrie for a mission to overthrow
hella which goes about as well as it can
for a plan that ends with the complete
destruction of asgard via fire giant oh
stop just for once in your life don't
smash
big monster
in wakanda t'challa's rule is challenged
by his cousin eric who teams up with
another evil arms dealer ulysses claw
there are a lot of evil arms dealers in
these movies eric betrays claw in order
to gain favor with wakandans he
seemingly kills t'challa and takes over
but t'challa returns and regains control
of his country i never hear that
and as you can see
i am not dead
after six years of waiting around thanos
decides to personally seek out the
infinity stones and the results are
devastating he kills loki and nearly
obliterates the last surviving
asgardians an attack on earth leads to
things getting so desperate that the
whole avengers crew except hawkeye and
ant-man who are under house arrest for
violating the sokovia accords need to
get back together to sort it out they
don't do so well
[Music]
dude you're embarrassing me from the
wizards i'm sorry i either i can't or he
won't like i know hey stand down keep an
eye on him despite fighting on two
fronts with one small team in space and
a massive force on earth thanos gathers
the stones snaps his fingers and kills
half the life forms in the universe
dissolving them into dust as he
dissolves nick fury uses the space pager
to alert captain marvel that earth needs
her help a month later captain marvel
and the surviving avengers track thanos
down in space only to find out that he's
destroyed the stones thor beheads thanos
and the avengers returned home having
won this battle while losing the bigger
war weirdly enough all this happens
while ant-man is involved in a
relatively low stakes heist movie when
the snap happens he's left stranded in
the quantum realm which turns out to be
an extremely lucky coincidence while
he's there five years go by during which
the heroes deal with the horrific trauma
of losing trillions of lives in various
mostly unhealthy ways thanks to an
assist from the most heroic rat in the
universe ant-man returns from the
quantum realm where for him only a few
hours have passed when he reunites with
the avengers the heroes realize that the
solution to their problem is time travel
with the help of iron man and the now
smart hulk the heroes travel back to
various key points in the timeline to
gather up the infinity stones of those
eras along with mjolnir circa 2013 they
also inadvertently bring the thanos of
2014 forward to 2023 along with all of
his minions right before he starts
attacking the hulk uses a rebuilt
infinity gauntlet to wish everyone back
to life and virtually every hero in the
entire mcu takes thanos on at once the
final blow is dealt by iron man who dies
on the battlefield like a freaking rock
star
after gathering for a funeral steve
rogers hops into the time stream to
return everything to where it should be
after living a full life with peggy
carter in an alternate past he returns
to this world one more time as an old
man to bequeath his shield to sam wilson
the falcon naming him the new captain
america
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
you